after this Jesus went to the other side
of the Sea of Galilee also called the
sea of Tiberias a large crowd kept
following him because they saw the signs
that he was doing for the sick Jesus
went up the mountain and sat down with
his disciples now the Passover the
festival of the Jews was near when he
looked up and saw a large crowd coming
toward him Jesus said to Philip where
are we to buy bread for these people to
eat he said this to test him for he
himself knew what he was going to do
Philip answered him six months wages
would not buy enough bread for each of
them to get a little one of his
disciples Andrew simon Peters brother
said to him there is a boy here who has
five barley loaves and two fish but what
are they among so many people
jesus said make the people sit down now
there was a great deal of grass in the
place so they sat down about five
thousand and all then Jesus took the
loaves and when he had given thanks he
distributed them to those who were
seated so also the fish as much as they
wanted when they were satisfied he told
his disciples gather up the fragments
left over so that nothing may be lost so
they gathered up the fragments and from
them from the five barley loaves left by
those who had eaten they filled twelve
baskets when the people saw the sign
that he had done they began to say this
is indeed the prophet who has come into
the world
then Jesus realized that they were about
to come to take him by force to make him
King
he withdrew again to the mountain by
himself
then the Jews began to complain to him
because he had said I am the bread that
came down from heaven they were saying
is not this Jesus the Son of Joseph
whose father and mother we know how can
he now say I have come down from heaven
jesus answered them do not complain
among yourselves no one can come to me
unless drawn by the father who sent me
and I will raise that person up on the
last day it is written in the prophets
and they shall all be taught by God
everyone who has heard and learned from
the father comes to me not that anyone
has seen the Father except the one who
is from God he has seen the father
very truly I tell you whoever believes
his eternal life I am the bread of life
your ancestors ate the manna in the
wilderness and they died this is the
bread that comes down from heaven so
that one may eat of it and not die I am
The Living bread that came down from
heaven whoever eats of this bread will
live forever and the bread that I will
give for the life of the world is my
flesh this is a very rich text full of
symbols and allusions but I wanted to
start with in some ways this the simple
question of why does John take a story
which clearly was circulating around
because Matthew Mark and Luke all have
some version of it this feeding of the
5,000 like mark combines that with a
walking on the water and then instead of
simply showing it as a sign of Jesus
compassion moves into this lengthy
discussion of what it is to be the bread
of life and how he's the bread of life
it becomes just to kind of do a segue
what what John always says of his
miracles their signs that they always
point beyond themselves and here he says
here's what it points beyond I'm going
to give you a little sermon on bread
yeah absolutely it's interesting how
that term sign does pop up here a couple
of times at the beginning in the end of
the the story itself and it's a heavily
laden term in John and exactly how signs
are supposed to work is something that
we need to think about but the basic
story that needs to be told I think
about the feeding of the 5,000 is that
from very early on it probably had some
sort of Eucharistic symbolism if you
look at the way in which the story is
told in even in mark probably the
earliest version of this it's not simply
a story about sharing and about
compassion and about learning to do all
of that it's also a story about Jesus as
the primary exemplar and the cause of
that compassion that we now share with
one another and even the words breaking
and blessing that's right begins to
sound like it's talking about Christian
practice not just Jesus story it almost
sounds as if it's taken from the rubrics
of a first century worship book yeah
so that John might see in this story a
hint and Christian Eucharistic practice
is not surprising I think others were
probably doing so too and that John
would also see in the story of the
walking on the water something terribly
symbolic is not surprising because we
have that phrase in that story that
we've already encountered earlier on and
John it is I yep and here we have the
picture of Jesus calming the waters of
the sea as God does in the Psalms gone
who has control over the nature and a
marvelous way God who is that spirit
that rushes over the deep in the opening
of Genesis it's God who controls thanks
and so having Jesus used those words
that are the words of God's
self-revelation and Exodus probably is
not accidental birth and probably goes
back to prior to John a way of
understanding the significance of that
story as a revelation of the divine
power that's seen in present with Jesus
so that John should see in these very
popular early Christian stories
something that deserves further
reflection and elaboration not at all
surprising and that's what we get then
in Jesus lengthy discourse on the on the
bread of life so in some ways what is
doing is making more explicit what marks
already doing implicitly in Matthew
doing more implicitly with saying this
is not just a moment of wonder-working
but it has implications for Christian
faith and how we
yeah that's right and if you think about
all of those miracle stories in in John
I think one of the things that he's a
little bit nervous about is the way in
which other Christians are using miracle
stories as simple proofs of the deity of
Jesus and he he I think he has a
suspicion about that move and it might
be based on some of the same concerns
that moderns have you know can we verify
that there's something that's beyond
nature here and even if there is what
does it really prove no and so that's
why I think it's very careful to choose
the word sign rather than proof because
there's a pointer here and the pointer
depends not on the immediate
intelligibility of the action but on the
lens of faith with which one sees it and
one of the themes that comes up in that
bread of life discourse is the way in
which people are drawn to Jesus by the
Father you know they so it's it's not a
matter of being forced into a
relationship with Jesus and with God by
some sort of external evidence it's the
relationship itself that establishes the
possibility there are something
paradoxical there but I think materials
mostly and and they're always looking
for Calvin under every verse and they
keep hoping that this drawing will be
some kind of it's destined from the
beginning right but I think it's much
more complicated than that I think I
think the drawing leaves a kind of
interesting balance between what the
believer does and what God does
right we bumped up against this a little
bit ago when we were seeing the the
business about judgment and when
judgment takes place and his judgment
sort of a predetermined thing or does it
come from the action of the person being
judged
exactly and John in a very non
Presbyterian non Lutheran way seems to
affirm you know what's the action yeah
the tiny determines that the judgment is
and you know there there are other
strands of the theological tradition
that have wrestled with this and looked
at passages like the Father as draw and
medieval Catholic theology for instance
would talk about prevenient grace yes
and they picked up in some of the
Protestant dogmatic traditions too so
something like something that some is a
dialectic between reserved God and
humankind that that is imaged by the
miracles of
and his status visa V God is not proven
by those miracles I think that's what
John wants to say so well what is it
then that John sees in these miraculous
signs the multiplication of the bread
and the loaves that pushes to a deeper
meaning how do you well partly I think
he's doing what we've seen before he's
taking stories that they will know in
this case the story of the man and the
wilderness and saying all right here's a
nice example of what God has done in the
past now the same guy getting used to
act only more so then in time of need
God gave you bread that will not perish
that that perishes now I'm giving you
bread that lasts for eternity then God
gave you bread that was little pieces of
manna now God gives you bread that is
save wha once again I am the bread of
life I'm the one for whom you've been
looking and it plays very nicely with
the woman what's the water you really
need it's living water
what's the bread you really need its
bread from heaven who is the living
water Jesus I'm the living water
who is the bread that lasts to eternal
life that's me too as a matter of fact
mmm absolutely right I want to get back
to the the final point there and how it
is that Jesus the same way functions as
the bread of life but there is one
little technical thing that I think is
is worth noting we talked in some of our
earlier conversations about Midrash as a
technique of John that is the
exploration of Scripture and all of this
bread of life discourse can actually be
analyzed very nicely as a traditional
Jewish Midrash on the text of a Psalm
Psalm 74 the bread from heaven he gave
them meat you're not referring to the
manna yeah and what Jesus does is to
comment on that Sam and take each
individual element of it and find some
way of referring it to something in his
own experience himself right it's not
manna in the past yeah is this bread now
which is me it's not he gave he gives
them the here now not Moses who gave it
God knows it's God you know and it's not
to eat in a physical sense it's to what
mmm that's where the and they were in my
I don't know how you how you unpack that
eating at the
the metaphorical level in John I see it
working in in two ways one there's
another scriptural text that's brought
in you are taught of God
what'a to write not those who eat yeah
again it's the conceptual or the
intellectual yeah it's just like the
wisdom business right dining at wisdoms
table that's right so it's coming out of
the same tradition that we saw working
in the the episode of the woman at the
well where water serves as the symbol
for this intellectual spiritual thing
but John it seems to me pushes it a
little further in this case so it's not
simply understanding some sort of
propositional truth or gaining access to
some esoteric revelation it comes to the
point at which we concluded the reading
it is my flesh yep that I give for the
life of the world now and at one level
that seems to bring us back to the the
literal and the physical and the the
verses that follow at the end of that
discourse seem to point in that
direction push in that direction you
have to chomp if you don't you if you
don't know me yeah yeah you won't ever
live the word that's used there is a
very calm well the word that yeah as you
say it would be used for a couch you
mean yeah yeah or someone munching a
hoagie exactly right and so that's the
kind of eating that you have to do and
that seems to point in a kind of
Sacramento's original direction we are
consuming they the Eucharistic elements
is a scenic one on and that's indeed the
way it used to be read by lots of well
and that's the part where the hyper
Protestant Bultmann before - referred to
says the ecclesiastical redactor comes
in and changes it to make it more
Eucharistic right and code for
ecclesiastical redactor as you well know
I say this hesitantly is early Catholic
yeah and his idea is some some Catholic
got in there and took his Lutheran text
and got all the sacraments in there but
I'm with you I think I think it's of a
piece certainly by the time the gospel
writer gets ahold of it and I think the
way to connect it and to see what's
what's going on in in John's theological
assessment of the tradition is to see
where it is that we encounter the flesh
and what it is we do mean
flesh of Jesus and this could be a
reflection on the ritual action of
enacting the Lord's Supper because after
all what what do you remember that you
remember the death of Jesus until he
comes right and so the flesh that you're
encountering in this sappy ntral
discourse is the flesh that hangs on the
cross yeah
for what yes Lord God not do different
things right yeah the two are intimately
related both in the ecclesiastical
tradition but I think already in John
yeah and John never wants to give up
that concrete in order to get to me the
general and so he starts in this this
whole chapter six from the very concrete
story of Jesus giving disciples and
hungry disciples bread and fish meeting
their physical needs showing somehow his
divine power by walking on water
identifying himself as God peg or me a
going me yeah and then going on and
talking about the significance of that
and ultimately referring it to his his
death on the cross which now is
available to those who would be his his
disciples through the eyes of faith
through the inspiration of God God has
to be at work in this in order to make
it all work but ultimately it hinges on
seeing and believing what happens at the
moment of glorification
which is yet to come yeah but it will be
flesh it's also striking we didn't read
this passage but it is striking that at
the end of the story this is where
people begin to turn away that this that
that the story becomes concrete in this
kind of shocking way of flesh on a cross
manifested now in this meal is more than
some can take and they begin to turn
away from Jesus right and we spoke in
the past about the ways in which early
Christian experience is somehow mapped
onto the story of Jesus exactly and a
lot of it has to do with the
relationship between believers in Jesus
and non-believers mainly and Jewish
relatives probably probably cousins yeah
early Christians here the mapping seems
to point to what's going on within the
community and there may be the the
walkers away that's right yeah these are
people who have been part of the Jesus
tradition and all of a sudden there's
something they can't console exactly
well I do think that that that it's
always striking to me because I've been
a path
as well as a teacher that the ID that
they are mythological idea that Jesus
got these wholehearted believers around
him who then just stuck with it till the
day they died understands the gospel
stories and certainly miss States the
early history of the church that from
the beginning this belief stuff is tough
stuff both to believe it and to act it
out and that from the beginning people
will find that too hard to take and
wander away and this gospel I think
partly is encouraging folk to take it on
with all its risk like Nicodemus be born
again like the woman at the well spread
the word it's not this is not easy stuff
mm-hmm
yeah and pushes it in your face pushes
in your face time after time every time
that's exactly right
mm-hmm well a rich story a rich story a
good break yep